a banda
[Música]
vamos aprender aqui aprendi aprender a
empreender do zero
certo quem é que acredita que qualquer
pobre pode ficar rico beleza então vamos
aprender começar pequeno
vamos começar pequeno beleza a primeira
coisa que a gente tem que aprender a
transformar um real em dois reais 2
reais em quatro reais e assim por diante
e pra isso a gente tem que conhecer os
critérios da multiplicação
quem é que acredita que com uma nota de
dez reais
a gente pode mudar de vida que todo
pobre pode ficar rico com uma nota de
dez reais pra isso
a primeira coisa que você tem que
entender é o seguinte pra você fazer
para você começar a empreender com 10
reais
você tem que começar com um produto que
todo mundo conheça algo que seja fácil
as pessoas olhar já saber sentir sentir
o gosto porque com isso a gente evita de
perder muito tempo explicando que o tipo
de produto que a gente está vendendo e
com apenas dez reais
a gente vai conseguir transformar a vida
de qualquer pessoa
eu trouxe aqui um produto que
praticamente todo mundo conhece e que
ele encostou trouxe a nota aqui dez
reais e 10 reais
quem é que gosta de paçoca legal eu
também gosto de paçoca
só aqui tem 50 quilos de passar roca
brincadeira pessoa tem hambúrguer
churrasco
tem de tudo em hot dog trouxe aqui um
pacote de paçoca que me custou 10 reais
dentro desse pacote de paçoca contém 50
paçoca
cada passo a cabeça me custou 20
centavos beleza bom
o critério aqui a gente oferecer um
produto que as pessoas já conhecem então
todo mundo conhece paçoca certo pra
gente criar uma venda que realmente faz
sentido a gente tem que conhecer
primeiramente a mente humana como ela
funciona na hora da compra a mente
humana ela funciona de duas formas a
primeira dela é o racional eo irracional
o que a pessoa faz ela pensa ou será que
preciso de paçoca fica complicado né
mas para você vender um automático
você tem que conseguir ativar o lado
emocional
a partir do momento que você consegue
ativar o lado emocional na sua venda ou
você consegue vender qualquer coisa não
importa o que você esteja vendendo você
consegue vender porque quando você faz
que o emocional compre de você
ele automaticamente já avisa por
racional que ele já comprou e racional
vai falar se vai ser a que comprou
será que se precisa mesmo essa passou a
conca aí o emocional ficar eu preciso
comprar essa paçoca
eu preciso dessa paçoca
então o que a gente vai aprender aqui é
ativar na venda o lado emocional das
pessoas na hora da compra
beleza e de que forma que a gente ativa
o lado emocional criando uma boa oferta
que não é no mercado publicitário chama
the kop de vendas com uma boa copa de
vendas com um bom texto você consegue
vender qualquer coisa eu trouxe aqui
uma cópia de vendas que qualquer pessoa
que quiser vender paçoca consegue vender
paçoca consegue pessoal isso funciona
funciona e muito tá eu trouxe um texto
aqui meu sonho é ser empresário tudo tem
um começo
só com um real qualquer pessoa que quer
empreender do zero e levam a mensagem
como essa a pessoa não precisa de paçoca
mas ela vai comprar de você
a paçoca pra te ajudar ela vai falar
assim eu preciso comprar essa
possam ajudar esse cara legal
pessoal o intuito aqui é vender
não importa que a pessoa pensa de você
ou se ela tinha o odeia você ou se ela
passa a gostar de você
mas o intuito é no final de tudo você
embora com todas as paróquias vendidas
e quando você ativa o lado emocional da
pessoa automaticamente você vende
com isso se você conseguir vender quatro
pacotes de paçoca por dia
lembrando que um passo um pacote de
passar a cabeça tem 50 paçoca
se a gente vender ela a r$1 vamos vender
essa paz oca a r$1 nós conseguimos no
final do mês de incríveis
vendemos 200 paçoca por dia 200 reais de
faturamento diário
se nós conseguimos vender quatro pacotes
de paçoca por dia e trabalharmos somente
20 dias e descansar uns dez dias
olha isso que privilégio descansar dez
dias
nós chegamos no incrível faturamento
são 4 mil de salários por mês
pessoal um salário como esse
muitos profissionais não consegue não
consegue ter um salário como esse
através de uma boa cópia de venda uma
boa oferta você consegue vender qualquer
coisa
basta você querer beleza
meu nome é jefferson começou a
empreender com oito anos de idade meu
primeiro é meu primeiro contato com o
empreendedorismo
foi numa banca de feira que minha mãe
tinha ela vendia roupa na feira e com
oito anos de idade
eu tomei conta dessa barraca sozinho por
muito tempo
meu primeiro emprego foi com 18 anos de
idade e aos 18 anos de idade trabalhando
em uma fábrica de chuveiros nessa
empresa eu fiquei por dois anos e por
dois anos eu conseguir receber 12
promoções meu 1º negócio foi aos 20 anos
era uma locadora de vídeo
nessa locadora de vídeo eu não tenho
junto com uma pizzaria e e essa pizzaria
com locadora era no meio de duas
locadoras
era muito difícil de você ter o cliente
e trazer o cliente para a sua locadora
porquê porque o cliente vem da direita
ele tinha que passar por uma locadora
o cliente vem da esquerda ele tinha que
possa provocar dor era eu tive incrível
sacada de não tirar o cliente dentro de
casa então ele não passava por nenhum
uma locadora ele recebia no conforto das
casas deles
a pizza e o filme todo o final de semana
para ele assistir e detalhe a gente
buscava também na segunda-feira de graça
aí foi que veio à pirataria que vocês
conhecem e quebrou meu negócio
mas ok não desisto
vamos o segundo negócio montei entrei
por ramo de telefonia celular no ramo de
telefonia celular
comecei a me especializar e fui aos
poucos através do estudo me tornando a
maior referência de são paulo
no ramo de telefonia celular montei uma
das vans nas portas dos principais
magazines
não sei se vocês sabem mas naquela época
os celulares haviam bloqueado
todos os celulares haviam bloqueado pela
operadora e para desbloquear você tinha
duas formas ou você pagava para uma loja
especializada desbloquear o seu celular
ou então você pagava operadora
desbloquear o seu próprio celular que
você já tinha comprado e você tinha que
pagar 11 uma taxa extra que eu fiz
montei uma van que parava nas principais
lojas principais magazines de são paulo
na frente o cara saía de dentro da da
loja ele já desbloqueava o celular
dentro da minha vã e com isso eu
consegui
praticamente quebrou quase todas as
lojas de celular de são paulo de
conserto o que aí veio o diga não ao
bloqueio
não sei se vocês lembram dessa época e
era em todos os jornais revista bloqueio
não bloqueio não bloqueio não e mais uma
vez eu quebrei ok mas eu não desistir
não vamos o terceiro negócio
usei as vans e entrei por uma operadora
de celular e comecei a fazer os cálculos
aonde estava embargada onde podia ganhar
dinheiro
descobrir dentro do regime operacional
da operadora que eu pagava 4 50 no chip
e ele me pagava uma comissão de 45 reais
para ativar um plano de controle
então eu comecei esse bom as pessoas
o critério de tudo você entender como
funciona a mente humana
paramos essas vans na frente
trouxe estações de trem onde tinha
grande fluxo de pessoas e de tráfico de
pessoas e começamos simplesmente falar
que o chip é de graça
chipp de graça chip de graça que
aconteceu um problema aí a operadora
descobriu a sacada e foi lá e comprou
todas as estações de trem e metrô
ok não desistir não lá atrás eu aprendi
a não tirar o cliente dentro de casa
então vamos usar a mesma estratégia para
não tirar o cliente dentro de casa já
que ele estava ativando os celulares
as linhas dentro dos magazines dentro
das estações
então agora não é que desativar a linha
vazando em tempo a gente já vai ligar o
cliente ativar na casa dele
foi aí que eu tive a grande sacada de
montar um sistema de televendas dentro
da operadora
aonde eu comprava o meia nem de todos os
clientes que saíam das operadoras de
celulares com os números pré pagos e eu
no conforto da casa deles ativava um
plano controle novamente
aí foi que a operadora descobrir
novamente a nossa sacada e a gente
quebrou de novo
beleza não vamos desistir
só que agora a ideia era transformar
criar algo de médio longo prazo já
estava cansado de criar coisas que eu
ganhava muito dinheiro muito rápido mas
depois eu quebrava
foi aí que o ano no ano de 2013 eu
montei a airbus uma marca que nasceu na
periferia de são paulo
lá no extremo leste guaianases e com no
primeiro ano já 20 já vestia os
principais artistas e jogadores de
futebol
era uma marca é uma marca voltada o
público do fant público ostentação
e naquela época quando a gente lançou a
marca o sonho de todo e me se era vestir
a nossa marca por que ele trazia
realmente o dna que eles buscavam que
eles cantavam nas músicas
eles falavam de ostentação mas falar
mais usavam roupas que não passavam essa
mensagem usavam marcas que as pessoas
que os proprietários dessas marcas não
gostava que ele simplesmente usavam as
marcas deles então quando nós acolhemos
essas pessoas esses funkeiros
eles também acolher a gente como a
principal marca pra eles usar e eles
passaram a usar em todos os programas de
tv jornal revista e foi aí que a gente
começou a ganhar uma grande proporção
programas de tv programas de jornais
revistas e pequenas empresas grandes
negócios revista veja
foi aí que eu consegui chegar no palco
do shark tank brasil quem conhece shark
tank brasil
alguém aqui assistiu o episódio o legal
lá a gente consiga um investimento e
conseguiu entrar hoje nos principais
magazines que praticamente era
impossível a gente entrar através de uma
simples a cada ajudar quem realmente
precisava de ajuda às presidiárias
usávamos a mão de obra de pessoas que
eram totalmente esquecidas dentro do
presídio
demos a ela dignidade
ensinamos a trabalhar ensinar costurar e
elas produzem os nossos produtos em
troca nós pagamos um salário para elas e
isso acabou transformando a vida de
muitas presidiárias
eu queria deixar antes de ir embora com
um recado que independente da gente está
do outro lado do rio
qualquer pessoa pode chegar aonde ela
quiser
não importa o que falam pra você que a
eu acho
na minha opinião que a única forma de
mudar a periferia é levando o
empreendedorismo pra dentro da periferia
dando a eles a dignidade ensinando a
fazer cálculos financeiros ensinando a
empreender com maestria e que empreender
transforma a vida das pessoas
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]